[Music]
my research agenda in charitable giving
actually started back in the late 90s
and a lot of people ask me
why did you get involved in working on
the science of charitable giving
and
a lot of times they assume it's because
of my altruism
and i tell them that's not the case
what happened was i was an assistant
professor at the university of central
florida in 1998
an assistant professor means you're the
lowest on the on the poll right right
nobody gives a damn about you you know
you're just trying to do the best you
can so i'm sitting in orlando florida in
my office minding my own business
and i hear a knock on the door
i open my office door and there's the
dean
of the college of business standing in
my doorway
so i say dean his name was thomas keon
uh dean tom how can i help you he says
john
i want to start a center for
environmental policy analysis
and i want you to help me start that
center
and your first job is going to be to
raise money
so i'm thinking
what i've never raised any money before
i'm a truck driver's son what's going on
here
so
he said think about it
and come back to me
so i thought about it for a few days and
i went to the dean's office and i told
him
this is a great opportunity
and i will do it
if you satisfy two conditions
one condition is
i want to run the fundraiser as a field
experiment
because i want to learn about why people
give
what keeps them committed to the cause
and two
i need some upfront money
and that's what i kind of learned in
those two days is i went out and talked
to a bunch of fundraising specialists
and they told me
the key is to have upfront money
so the dean gave me five thousand
dollars
big whoop right
but importantly he gave me a big list of
potential donors
who i could ask to give money to
the center for environmental policy
analysis okay now i'm in business
my my research agenda has always been
to use the world as my lab
and if you're ever trying to accomplish
something
do it scientifically
so you can not only figure out what
works and why but then you can get it
right the next time
so
i did this fundraiser
and
what i first learned was
i talked to dozens
of fundraising gurus
practitioners
strategists etc etc etc and they all had
rules of thumb
they all said things like
use a three to one match rather than a
one to one match because a three to one
match will raise more money when i say
three to one i mean for every hundred
dollars somebody gives
the charity matches it with three
hundred dollars that's a three to one
match versus a one to one you know all
these
all these great anecdotes and each time
i would ask them
can you give me the data
behind
these gut feelings no i can't i said
well how do you know they're true
and every person said well that's just
how we always do it that's how my boss
did it now i'm thinking holy cow this is
two to three percent of the gdp of our
nation is charitable giving right two or
three percent of wallet is giving of
money forget about the time you know add
add volunteerism to that and you might
get seven percent of gdp so it's a very
important sector
but when i learned
that it's mostly built on anecdotes i
said
man we're in business
because now i can use this as a is a
research agenda
to explore generosity
and i can help charities
use science
to raise more money so i've been at that
for now close to 25 years
partnering with charities
helping them raise more money helping
them leverage science
and you end up learning some really
interesting facts about people
for like for example
when you look at what drives a man to
give versus a woman
uh a man is driven a lot by the tax
advantages
that charitable giving gives you that's
called the price effect
in giving whereas
women are driven more
by altruism and social pressure
so now these become two sort of
important features that
you might say well that affects
charitable giving and that's about
generosity
but what about other parts of society
like tipping
is can can we take what we learn
about the generosity to
you know the sierra club or the united
way or what have you
and apply those elements to
what happens in the world of tipping
somebody whether it's an uber driver
or tipping a waiter or what have you
and it's sort of interesting because
sometimes you can
and sometimes you can't
like one example is when you look at
the charitable giving data
so i have the irs data so i have
everyone's tax form from like 2008
to 2017
so i can explore
all kinds of different cuts of those
data
and i can tell you
that as it turns out at each income
percentile so if you say the average
income earner in the united states is
like 58 000
if you look at all people who make that
amount of money
women give a lot more than men
in that income bucket
so you look across all of the income
buckets
and a fact is
is that women in every income bucket
give more than men
to charitable causes so now you'd say
okay
that must be also true in tipping
it's not
in fact it's just the opposite in
tipping
so you can say well where's john getting
his tipping data from
i was a chief economist at uber
back in 2017
and
tk travis kalanick came to me and said
john you need to help us
keep the drivers in uber because there's
this crazy delete uber campaign hashtag
the lead uber campaign
that's killing us on the both the driver
and the rider side
and my solution back then was let's roll
out tipping on the app
so we rolled out tipping on the app my
team at uber was called ubernomics so
team ubernomics helped roll out tipping
and what we find there is across the
board
men tip a lot more than women
so there's sort of this interesting
dynamic that
in charitable giving
where you do it face to face
or you do it to be recognized women are
giving a lot more than men but remember
on the uber app
what happens is you do it anonymously
and you don't do it face to face and in
that case men actually give more than
women in tips
what are some of the
learnings
around increasing frequency or amount of
tipping
from your your many experiments there
are sort of some interesting facts about
what happens
in that uber car
okay so a first fact is
that if your listeners want to join the
one percent
a lot of times people say i want to be
in the one percent
now in this case
only one percent of writers
tip every trip
that kind of blew my mind that's wild i
never would have guessed that yeah
because in that charitable giving game
like nine out of ten
people give to a charitable cause at
least once every year
but when you think about
the uber experience only one percent
of people tip every time
and interestingly
roughly
60
never tip
wow
now in the middle of course are the
sometimes tippers
so we did this big
data just
big data grab from our experiment so now
we're talking about 23 million
observations a big data set
and we can look at a lot of averages and
what you find are things
like men tip female drivers more than
they tip male drivers
that's a fact especially when
the female drivers are younger
so what happens is the older female
drivers say 60 years old and beyond
those female drivers are tipped the same
as the male drivers in that age group
but the big difference is with the 21 to
25 year old drivers where females earn
about six percent more in tips than the
males do
and that it's all driven by male riders
which is sort of an interesting fact
now i'm going to let your imagination
uh tim go with that about why that
happens i don't want to go into that
here i'll let your imagination go i
don't have to imagine very long
continue
please
but there are all these kinds of facts
like this you know the average trip only
about 15
of trips are tipped
and
conditional on tipping the average tip
is about 10 12
of the fare
so you do have things like a bigger bill
is is a bigger tip that's what we have
in restaurants too where people tip 20
percent
but the big thing about tipping is
people tip a lot more
if it's face to face
versus when it's anonymous so the way we
did tipping at uber
was you don't get asked to tip
until after the ride is done and you're
removed in space and time from the
driver
and we did that on purpose because tk
said john
i don't want tipping to be attacks
on riders i want it to be something
that is truly done for exceptional
service
we want to separate it in space and time
and then that's what we got is you know
roughly 15 percent of trips are tipped
you